hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt in meinem letzten video wo es
mal kein rezept gab habe ich euch ja
meine drei küchenmaschinen vorgestellt
und habe so ein bisschen allgemeines
darüber erzählt und in meinem video
heute möchte ich jetzt nur auf die
kennwort eingeben
weil ich ja im nächsten video dann auf
die kitchenaid eingehen werden
und in meinem letzten video haben wir ja
schon darüber geredet dass es nicht die
perfekte küchenmaschine gibt sondern
jeder muss für sich wissen war es die
perfekte küchenmaschine für einen selber
ist oder ob man überhaupt alle braucht
und in diesem video möchte ich jetzt
einfach auf die kennwort eingehen und
die gibt es ja auch bei uns im shop
neben der kitchenaid und ich möchte euch
einfach mal vorstellen natürlich was
unser set beinhaltet also was da alles
dazugehört dabei ist aber ich stelle
euch auch noch zusatz zubehör vor was
eben vielleicht auch interessant sein
könnte und ich will jetzt einfach mal
sagen ich starte mit dem video und falls
ihr noch weitere fragen habt oder
anregungen oder gern noch ein anderes
zusatzzahl sehen würdet dann schreibt
mir einfach in die kommentare
und dann werde ich das einfach
irgendwann nochmal mit einbauen zuerst
möchte ich euch kurz mal sagen was die
maschine kann und zwar ist es eine
vision verschiedene die eben rühren kann
und nixon fahren drehen kann
sahne aufschlagen aber sie kann eben
noch was besonderes und zwar hat sie
hier ein induktionskochfeld und deswegen
kann dieser maschine auch erhitzen und
ich habe immer gesagt als die maschinen
und ich hatte und auch noch nicht kannte
ich hatte eher den
die kitchenaid der thermomix war super
um zb den soßen zu kochen und die
kitchen etwas super um kuchen tage zu
hören
und ich habe immer gesagt es müsse ein
kombigerät geben was beides kann und es
ist einfach so in dieser kennwort
cooking chef so dass sie einfach beides
kann und eben auch sehr groß ist also
des welt was für eine einzelperson auch
weil wir keine dort kleine menge drin zu
bereiten
aber man kann eben auch für große
fraktionen kochen und einfach große
portionen zu bereiten weil die schüssel
sakko sind und sie hat einfach enorm
viel zubehör und ich möchte ganz so
lange um den heißen brei herumreden
sondern zeigt euch einfach mal die
küchenmaschine in aktion
was ich jetzt vorneweg muss sagen muss
also was bei dieser maschine natürlich
sehr gut ist ist die qualität und ich
habe echt schon einige küchenmaschinen
gehabt ich hatte auch eine maus und
discounter die kennt ihr noch und bei
der maschine ist also das ist ja eine
auf august und sie ist selbst stabil
auch die einzelelemente und die
zubehörteile sind sehr stabil und
qualitativ hochwertig jetzt hier bei
diesem schneebesen zb der große
portionen kopf getreten
und der besteht komplett aus edelstahl
anders als bei anderen maschinen die
eben nicht auf edelstahl besteht denn
hier kann man zum beispiel einfach in
die spülmaschine speisen bei anderen
geht es eben nicht und wenn ich dir
jetzt einsetzen will lege ich das ja und
dann kann ich das hier ein bereich
drehen und ich möchte zu euch hier an
diesem beispiel zeigen was so die große
leistung dieser küchenmaschine ist und
zwar ist es ziemlich schwer für große
geräte ein
so schlage ich möchte ich brauch selten
nur ein eiweiß aber ich mach das jetzt
einfach mal durch solche paradebeispiel
um zu zeigen dass wir uns eben aufhören
können aber die kann auch 10 1 weise
schlafen also das kann sie auch und
wichtig hierbei ist dass es überhaupt
bis an den boden der schlüssel kommt und
das eiweiß steif schlagen kann
sie geht es um zubehörteile und ich kann
hier oben regeln wie tief dieser
schneebesen nach unten geht und deshalb
einfach so weit runter gehen wird das
grabmal noch so ein blatt papier
darunter hindurch könnte selbst kann
nämlich dieser schnee wesen des
unwirklichen und jetzt schalte ich hier
einfach auf die höchste stufe ganz
langsam und dann soll das eiweiß steif
geschlagen werden
[Musik]
unten habe ich dann steigt bei schnee
und dessen ist der maschine erst mal
hinkriegen ein einziges eiweiß
aufzuschlagen das kann wirklich nicht
jeder maschine also mit meiner alle
küchenmaschine ging es nicht mit der
kitchenaid und mit dieser hier geht's
auch kein organ das weiß natürlich was
ganz einfach es für die kennwort aber
ich zeige euch jetzt in dem kontext mal
die anderen elemente und zwar sind es
diese hier
ich habe jetzt den schneebesen hier
nicht mehr dabei da ist aber dreckig mit
der bse masse hier habe ich zum beispiel
mit haken und mein mann macht war immer
den captain hook tat weil das einfach so
einen riesen knethaken ist und da kann
wirklich beim teig kneten zum beispiel
einfach die bewegungen der hand
nachmachen und knetet dem hefeteig
einfach richtig schön durch ich stelle
ackermann hefeteig rein kam dann zum
beispiel wesentlich hefeteig mache die
temperatur einschalten auf etwa 30 35
grad und dann geht man im hefeteig
direkt im anschluss auf oder manchmal
auch schon während den kneten und es ist
einfach ein riesen vorteil
und das ist einfach so massiv it geräte
die auch wirklich gut in der hand liegen
hier habe ich ein kopftuch element und
zwar ist es etwas zum beispiel wenn er
im urlaub machen wollt die maschine kann
erhitzen bis 140 grad und da fangen
natürlich auch der rest argument
weil bei 132 noch gut ja schlau wie
heißt de und französisch mit sorge
französische chemiker
ja ja genau man muss wer weiß wie dieser
begriff heißt da fangen an der rest
aromen er sich zu bilden die bei 132
fahrzeuge
das sagt mein mann und ich so ein
werkzeug das dritte in der mitte und
dreht auch aus moralischen gewissen und
das soll zum beispiel sein um außen bis
äußeren rinnen zu bringen und es innen
nach außen also das gerät
entgegengesetzt und wenn man dann zum
beispiel ein gulasch macht was nur
gelegentlich gerührt werden soll dann
kann man eben dieses werkzeug benutzen
was ein optimales bruder schweben
zusammengehören und weiter erkennen
wodurch es auch so dass ich da wenn ich
die temperatur drauf habe einfach drei
intervall stunden habe entweder kann ich
ständig rühren lassen
das brauche ich zum beispiel bei einem
risotto oder wenn ich eine suppe kochen
oder irgendwas sich ständig hören muss
dann nämlich intervall stufe eins bei
intervall stufe zwei wird gelegentlich
gerührt und bei intervalle stufe 3 das
letzte spiel das mit dem hula spielt
ganz selten nur gehört und dessen
nämlich zum beispiel auch um eine
schokolade zu schnell fuhr
quartiere zu teilen parieren anstelle
einer reaktion ihrer fast wir haben's
meine reaktion immer ab 132 grad
und dieser jahre aktion ist wichtig weil
wenn man fleisch anbrät des bei 132 grad
anfängt zu rüsten mit dieser maria
reaktion und erst dann kommen eben die
aromastoffe raus und es ist einfach
wichtig das zu erwähnen weil die
maschine das kann
es gibt ja anderen küchenmaschinen die
erhitzen aber die erhitzen bis 99 oder
100 grad
und da können diese röstaromen gar nicht
entstehen das fleisch wird nicht
gebraten sondern es in stratford einfach
im eigenen saft und wir brauchen ja bei
gulasch zum beispiel oder anderen
fleischgerichten einfach diese
röstaromen weil die das gleich so
richtig schön schmackhaft machen
sie haben wir dann zum beispiel den
kraken und zwacken wenn man ein paar
sieht und das ist so ein haken den
benutzt nur zum beispiel verzehr teige
also ich würde es damit zum beispiel in
frankreich verrühren denen eben zuerst
in den topf auf anbraten in dieser
kennwort und daneben das nehmen um dann
eben weiter zu machen
das ist sehr gut für feste urteile auf
einfach teige die sich nicht mit zum
beispiel für diesen hier verhüllen
lassen mit der gummilippe daran dass
sich also ein flacher flexibler mit
diesem gummi liebchen
und da kann man einfach komplett aus der
schüssel alles rausgekommen alles wird
perfekt verrührt und es nämlich auch
ganz gerne türe zu schmelzen weil da
einfach die komplette kuvertüre verrührt
wird und er bis heute nicht mal dem
fahrrad
das hilft ist von werkzeugmaschinen
meiner mama und es ist einfach ein
unterschied dass es aus plastik pause
jetzt mal einen teil hier
und das hier ist ein paar aus edelstahl
und mit dem kommt man echt nicht weit
weil das hier auf alles kaputtgeht 1
kaputt ich auch schon kaputt das habe
ich in der firma beim ausprobieren eines
tages und ja daran erkennt man die gute
qualität und was wir hier noch dabei
haben zu diesem flexible hat gibt es
einfach mal weg und die kann man hier
entfernen
so kann man zum beispiel rausnehmen und
die andere einsetzen wenn ich zum
beispiel sagen ich möchte jetzt ist
grauer nur für meine süßen speisen und
schwarze für mal gekocht und schalten
kann zum beispiel auch machen als
nächstes reichlich dimic punkt zu holen
und zwar haben wir hier diesen mix aus
dem kunststoff russischen weg den ich
dicker kunststoff und sag ich doch ihm
und hopp habe ich mich vergessen dass
sich der aufsatz mit dem ich das drauf
machen und bei canon wird das so da hat
er mehrere auch selbst kann hier oben
auf fernstrecken briggs dran stecken
hier vorne ist nun an steckplatz und
hier unten die früher elemente wobei
kennen würdig ist richtig optimal war
man jetzt denkt oh gott jetzt weiß ich
gar nicht welches gerät wo anschließend
muss aber es ist so dass jede jeder
anschluss in anderen ein anderes symbol
hat vorn sitzt man hier ist das dreieck
da ist es ein tolles davon essen strich
also ganz einfach gesagt und deswegen
weiß man immer so formation stecken muss
da kann ich jetzt drauf
und können wir jetzt entweder mit dem
mixer darin was mixen
hier habe ich noch den deckel drauf und
der daneben auch diese einstellung von
16 kanada mixen oder schnell
oder man nimmt das mixa rocks hier und
da diese scheiben und da gibt es
insgesamt sechs verschiedene zum
beispiel für etwas größere stücke
vorstellen stifte oder für feine stücke
zu schreiben
dicke scheiben dünnen scheiben und so
weiter das wären jetzt zum beispiel die
hier das hin so die sechs scheiben die
dabei sind ein schatten auch hier und da
kann einfach sein gemüse in wirklich
jede form schneiden die man bräuchte ich
zeig euch jetzt wie ich damit meine
schokolade fand das mache ich gar nicht
gern weil es einfach sehr schnell geht
und ich mir enorm viel kraft und zeit
sparen
für mich ist das besonders ideal ich
mache viele motiv trocken und wenn ich
motiv mache ich bin nicht so der
buttercreme typ sondern eher der typ und
dann nehme ich einfach meine kuvertüre
und gebt sie da rein und er stoppt mir
einfach die erste arbeit das land sogar
zu stellen und hier drinnen kann man die
gans richtig schnell herstellen ich
zeige es auch wieso also es geht einfach
auf höchster stufe und las erst mal die
schokolade klein werden
hier oben mal rein also ich sehe die
schokolade ist richtig schön fein und
ich habe es jetzt mal absichtlich länger
laufen lassen uns was seht ihr hier
die schokolade war ja schon fein
gerieben dann wohl dass sie zum modell
schokolade und jetzt muss ich schon
wieder fast flüssig das weiß die hat die
maschine nach so viel power was durch
die reibung die schokolade auch erhitzt
wird und sogar schmelzen würde also
wenig zeit so etwas mehr schokolade drin
gehabt hätte er die sachen schafft dass
die schokolade wirklich auch günstig
wird dann kann man nur noch ein schluck
sahne dazugeben und hat die platte
keeper naschen und natürlich macht man
diesen mix aus stars jetzt nicht nur die
schokolade klein ich hatte da zum
beispiel auch meine haselnüsse oder
meine anderen nächste drin gut das mache
ich immer gerne weil einfach das aroma
von den ganzen mist viel aromatischer
schmidt und viel besser schmeckt es
schmeckt ganz frisch immer kann sogar
sein eigenes nuss muss zum beispiel
herstellen oder ich mach darin auch die
verschiedensten tipps und jetzt zeige
ich euch den mix aus kraft und zwar ist
es eine aus glas und der ist ganz
besonders gut weil er darin nicht noch
kalte sachen sondern auch heiß sachen
mixen kann also man kann zum beispiel
unten ihnen der pilot die suppe kochen
hier rein fühlen und sie einfach
pürieren und im internet kursiert noch
das alte modell als auch mit dem alu
mixa wir haben schon das neue modell mit
dem glas mixa finde ich auch super weil
in seinem auto mixa kann ich sehen was
jetzt dass sich gerade geschieht hier
kann man schnell zu gucken was passiert
schon los wir machen jetzt nämlich ein
e10 wird dir helfen erklärt was jetzt
macht und da kann man einfach jetzt
benutzen was man möchte dass ich auch
bei uns oft so wir haben immer ein
volles obst und gemüse fach aber
manchmal kommt einfach vor dass obst und
gemüse kurz kommt weil wir lassen ja
machen kleine stinker vielleicht ja und
dann kann man einfach jeden morgen
irgendwie so ein bisschen obst und
gemüse in den mixer packen und in black
ops muss sie draußen und ich mag es dann
werden wenn man es musik cremig ist und
etwas locker ist und es geht immer auch
nur an der letzte richtig power
und da ist der rechte aus computer
erkennt man natürlich auch wieder am
tropf
aber ich meine farm kann ich machen
und so hat man unter umständen innerhalb
von einer minute für die ganze familie
ein frühstück gemacht also das ist das
erste was ich morgens trinke und
irgendwann ein paar stunden später kommt
dann bis auf eine stimme
und jetzt möchte ich euch denen dankbar
einsatz zeigen das ist übrigens war fast
allen geräten dabei die einfach eine
koch funktion haben und dazu muss ich
auch gerne mal besagen zwischen relativ
kleinen im kleiderschrank einsatz
aber ich kenne auch keine küchenmaschine
mit kopf und die wirklich so einem
großen dampfer corp hat das ist einfach
für eine komplette familie reichen
könnte also hier an habe ich jetzt auch
schon zum beispiel klum und pool drinnen
gemacht dass ihn jetzt die überreste den
anderen habe ich schon gemacht aber ich
find die funktion trotzdem super aber
zum beispiel auch fisch fleisch oder
gemüse drin gar in hama und hier kann
ich jetzt übrigens mein wasser trinkt
wochen mit dem deckel drauf das mache
ich jetzt mache ich wenn dann die
temperatur erreicht ist hier dann öffne
ich die maschine auffassen wegen der
dampf da dürft euch nicht verbrennen
hier spricht nehmen kann ich hier den
einsatz gehen und kann jetzt zum
beispiel sagen okay 15 minuten das
reicht mein gemüse ich brauche nur etwas
weniger ich mag es fest und laßt die
maschine einfach wieder weiter
und dann habe ich ein perfekt
durchdachtes
je nach dem weg möchte bissfest oder
ganz weich und hab das einfach vitamin
schonend und mehr allein schon wegen
meiner kendrick schnitt und hier zeige
ich euch noch mal was ganz tolles und
zwar dieser spritzschutz hier
denn hier kann dann einfach weg nach dem
benutzen ich hatte jetzt den dampfgarer
drauf und ihr seht unten dran bleibt
alles schön sauber und vor allen dingen
kommt da einfach keine feuchtigkeit über
viele und ich muss später nicht dastehen
mit einem wattestäbchen und die maschine
irgendwie saubermachen versteckt diese
zeit einfach eine spülmaschine und
fertig bin ich mit der hygiene mit der
reinigung
als nächstes möchte ich euch gerne meine
gewürzmühlen zeigen und zwar ist es hier
einmal diese rolle und ich habe hier
schon mit dabei mit deckel und die finde
ich ganz super und die habe ich mir auch
gewünscht für mindset im shop weil ich
einfach gerne gewürze mag und diese auch
gerne so wie diesmal genüsse im ganzen
kauf wie hier zum beispiel unten pfeffer
den hatte ich mir mal aus der türkei
mitgebracht und ich mag das einfach das
gewürz dann selber zu malen oder zu
machen auch gewiss mischungen
herzustellen
ich nehme auch ganz gerne hier zum
beispiel kümmel im ganzen und mal dass
dann selber und so könnte ich mir jetzt
meine gewürzmischung zum beispiel für
meine lange spiesse zusammenstellen
einfach alles hier rein und dann den
deckel verschließen und dann einfach nix
je nach dem gebäude ist jetzt wer etwas
gröber ich kann es auch weiter mal da
habe ich ganz fein sind besser und jetzt
könnt ihr das immer so machen weil wir
ja viel städtchen haben und alle mit
deckel sind kann ich sehr übrigens alle
teile sind so im vorteil was ich kann
alles einzeln in den schneemassen
stecken damit keines zaubern und dann
keine insekten zu machen und deswegen
ich möchte einfach aufbewahren würde ich
jetzt aufschreiben oder wenn ich noch
was mit dazu gegeben habe gäbe es mich
schon lange zum beispiel und habe das
herz schädigen und bars cafés ist
natürlich super weil es keine gerüche an
als nächstes möchte den fleischwolf
zeichnet der auch im set mit dabei ist
und zwar wird das leid rollfilm vorne
dran gemacht
hier haben wir den hebel und anteilig
hier sehr flache einfach wegnehmen und
von da mein fleisch dran sein wenn es
mal nicht so schnell geht mit dem rhein
suchen
von ingo freyer aber hier klappt den
hebel müsste einfach betätigen dann
können doch einfach die maschine kurz
einschalten und dann dreht sich hier
wieder schnitzmeier unserem haus treiben
den fleischwolf habe ich mit drei auch
setzten einmal pro mittel und fein ich
nehme es im feinen und ich mache ganz
ganz fleisch selber um man hat gleich
selber weil ich einfach dann weiß was
drin steckt vor kurzem auf dieser
skandal mit dem kleine fleisch und so
weiter möchten wir auch nicht drin
natürlich hatten wir ein netzwerk des
vertrauens ich komme auch mal meinen
hackfleisch aber eigentlich macht es
prinzipiell gerne selber und es geht ja
auch so schnell und gar kein pakt ist es
ja wirklich so da kann euch jeder
irgendwas heimischen keller würde merken
ob es zwei schritten steigt oder
schweinefleisch oder irgendein
fleischers jetzt nicht drin haben wollte
und der größte vorteil ist aber wenn man
das fleisch sei gemacht ich kann einfach
bestimmen welches sich nehmen und wie
hoch der fettgehalt als ich habe zum
beispiel darf man frust fleisch genommen
aber wenn du nicht möchte dass bei merck
drin steckt nämlich einfach nur fertige
research oder ich kann sagen ich mich
jetzt rind und lamm für meine leckeren
frikadellen oder eben so fand er das
selber wissen wie man fleisch und eben
auch schmecken soll
und mit dem gleich machen wenn jetzt
sagt ich mag gar kein fleisch sondern
hier gibt es auch im sprit spritzgebäck
auf sub und damit kann man zum beispiel
an weihnachten dann leckere plätzchen
machen und da werde ich dann noch ein
rezept dazu machen und schönes
spritzgebäck geschafft ihr habt jetzt
den fleischwolf gesehen und ich sehe
heute etwas anders aus und zwar gegen
gestern unser licht aus und wir konnten
es nicht mehr weiter drin weil es
einfach viel zu dunkel wurde und
deswegen drehe ich jetzt heute weiter
aber für euch ist sein finden also ganz
okay durch wundern
ich habe jetzt euch die ausrüstung
gezeigt die ich in meinem set mit drin
habe also mit dem gemüse schneider dem
mixer und so weiter alles was wir bisher
gesehen haben und jetzt möchte ich euch
einfach noch ein paar zubehörteile
zeigen die es da nicht im set mit dabei
sind die aber auch noch zusätzlich von
uns auch bekommen könnt und das sind
eigentlich coole sachen die ich euch
einfach nicht vorenthalten wurde
ich habe hier zum beispiel einen
entsafter und wenn man jetzt denkt
entsafter wieso soll ich jetzt selber
saft herstellen ist kann man doch auch
alles kaufen
also ich finds halt richtig cool saft
herzustellen oder auch smoothies weil
ich einfach gerne frisches obst und
frisches gemüse immer und wir haben ganz
oft eben gemüse und obst daraus eben
vielleicht einmal ein paar tage um steht
man möchte vielleicht nicht mehr so
essen aber als musik oder als saft ist
muss dann gerne und beim sagt ich es
eben auch vorteil
und zwar gibt es zum beispiel die klaren
sätze wie zb apfelsaft und da wussten
zum beispiel viele nicht das oft so
setzt zb mit gelatine daneben gereinigt
werden damit sie überhaupt klar werden
weil sein apfelsaft wer hier gleich
rauskommt werden wir auch sehen der ist
ja gar nicht klar dass ich ja apfel und
das sich ebenso ein nachteil von
gekauften selbst muss nämlich nicht mit
drauf stehen und dann ist eben was
nichts für vegetarier veganer oder zum
beispiel muss liebe die eben keine
schweine gelatine zum beispiel essen
wollen und ich zeige euch das jetzt
einfach mal ich habe hier ein bisschen
obst und gemüse gerichtet und jetzt
machen wir mal einen leckeren salat
einen leckeren saft mich und mein mann
pickel salat gedacht und karotten hier
liegen haben aber alles gut und das ist
auch einer der vorteile wenn man so eine
maschine hat die einfach so zubehörteile
hat wenn man zum beispiel schon immer
mal in satter haben wollte kann man das
einfach mit ihr draufstellen muss nicht
noch zusätzlich in der maschine dazu
kaufen und ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie
das funktioniert
muss zugeben da einfach da ist schon
relativ laut aber guck mal bitte an wie
das hier ausgeht dass jedoch total
lecker aussage ich jetzt karotte drin
und apfel und ich stehe jetzt noch ein
paar orangen und gebt die auch rein
übrigens habe ich jetzt richtig große
äpfel aber wenn nämlich ganz große äpfel
habt zum beispiel auch äpfel aus dem
garten die sind auch nicht so mega groß
dann können das sogar ganz selbstlos
reinschmeißen also ihr müsst das obst
nicht sehr verfahren verkleinern weil es
hier oben in großen für richter und
jetzt gehe ich jedoch zwei orangen rein
da habe ich einfach ist die schale
entfernt und die kann ich jetzt im
ganzen dazu geben und das ist eben der
vorteil an dem großen führer hier und
jetzt schaut euch das man an wären hier
fast einen liter saft raus ich habe hier
drei karotten drin zwei äpfel und zwei
auch schon fast einen liter saft also
750 milliliter und woran erkennt man
jetzt einen guten entsafter ich möchte
natürlich wissen wie viel saft ob es
sich nämlich mal kurz und wie viel saft
wurde gewonnen und wie viel abfall da
denn wir wollen ja nicht dass der gute
saft verschwendet wird und zwar sehen
wir das hier
dieser ganze sache und wenn man da jetzt
drückt darf halt kein saft raus laufen
ich habe hier ein paar tropfen noch aber
das ist gar nicht schlimm dass ich
wirklich schon sehr gut und es waren bei
mir übrigens saft auction also der sich
auch mein tipp wenn ihr orangen haben
wollt zum saft aus präsident der saft
auch waschen dem viel mehr saft und das
problem
wie lecker das aus sind
der vorteil von dem lebt im vergleich
zur musik satt machen dass ich einfach
nur da um kurz mal so vitamine zu sich
zu nehmen
durstlöscher dass ich einfach frisch und
lecker und jetzt habe ich hier noch ein
zubehörteil und zwar ist es hier ein
kartoffel thema und zwar so ein gerät
dann kann man jetzt hier sehen sie
bilder mit drin
und hier bestätigung ist auch diesen
kleinen noppen jetzt geht man hier
wasser rein sondern schade da unten
verdächtig und jetzt kann man hier seine
kartoffel oder wie man will auch
karotten rhein geben aber die waren
vorher in kleinere stücke schneiden
wird diese maschine mehr die kartoffel
stehe aber schon dazu sagen es ist
einfach so in england funktioniert
dieses kritik sap weil da die kartoffeln
so eine norm haben und die haben alle
dieselbe größe und jesus auch wichtig
dass man kartoffel nimmt die alle gleich
groß sind die festwochen sind und dann
funktioniert das ganze
ich probierte es jetzt auch gerade zur
passen mal aus allerdings wird ich mir
glaube ich so ein gerät nicht kaufen
weil wir das mal kartoffeln ich jeden
tag essen und zweitens weiter sind für
mich eher ja ich muss darauf achten was
es für katar für uns ein wenig davon
ausgehen und deshalb bei uns die pfälzer
kombi geräte sind nicht alle
gleich groß und die stele mal einfach
per hand wenn man sie überhaupt stehen
braucht immer und jetzt scheint es hier
auf maximale stufe zwei starter und dann
warten wir einfach mal hier die uhr auf
null
und dann gucken wir einfach mal wie
lange das gedauert hat also die werte
hier einfach jetzt durch die bewegung im
topf hier am rand entlang
[Musik]
dann geschehen ich denke es kann mal
richtig voll machen weil die noppen sind
ja überall auch unter dem deckel
was sie tut es auch schon also die
ersten kartoffeln
es sind schon geschehen an einigen
stellen sich das
irgendwie doch ganz cool gesprochen
aber jetzt mal abgesehen davon dass ich
das brot oder nicht ich finde es
irgendwie auch ganz ohne zucker bei den
kartoffeln auch ist es sauberer als ich
könnte zum beispiel jetzt aufhören und
könnte jetzt mit diesen abgeschliffenen
kartoffeln sage ich mal zum beispiel
ofenkartoffeln machen und man hat
einfach schöne saubere kartoffeln muss
sie nur noch kurz ab spüren aber ich das
jetzt einfach mal komplett also nach
zwei minuten unser in die kartoffeln so
aus sie sind schon fast komplett
geschält jetzt kommt es darauf an will
man wirklich komplett aus der kartoffel
nur noch geld ist im ganzen der schalter
ist wo der arktis ist schon als er mir
wird es persönlich schon reichen weil
die kartoffel hat ja auch so kleine
augen und kleine vertiefungen dann
lassen wir mal zu ende gegangen ist
also es können was an wenn das ganze
gruppen kam noch einmal zählen zu
schauen besorgt oder würdig
also ich will gerade echt total positiv
überrascht weil die kartoffeln echt
super toll sauber werden ich habe jetzt
muss man hier natürlich das wasser weg
schicken kartoffeln ganz kurz abwaschen
ich glaube hier ist gerät doch zulegen
müsste auch warum wir uns von chance ja
wir haben sogar schon längst hätte bei
ich bin es irgendwie ganz cool wenn ich
zum beispiel gerade was vorbereitet und
es ist oft so dass ich dann eh schon
wieder kartoffel schälen waschen ich
mache zum beispiel ganz gern
ofenkartoffeln schneit die kartoffeln
einfach entscheiden und kleine spalten
und dann ab in den ofen und ich mache
das mit schale
das heißt es musste doch schon vorher
mühsam erstmal abwaschen und jetzt wo
ich einfach die katar und bahrain mit
ein bisschen basket esch war ich total
viel wasser weil ich das nämlich sonst
unter dem wasserhahn machen muss und
dann unter fließendem wasser die ablöste
und ich war einfach mit dir aber ich
stecke das jetzt in zukunft hier rein
und während die kartoffel gewaschen
werden kann im moment ist frau bereitet
ist stadt wurde wiederum geschlagen
wurde die konkurs ungefährlicher
ungefähr arbeiter waren jetzt auch
kleinere und größere daran das war okay
also ich finds echt ok und die
kartoffeln benutze ich jetzt um euch das
nächste super hat hals zeigen
als nächstes habe ich hier einen
zerkleinerer und zwar zu tun hat der
alles was ihr hineinsteckt in kleine
würfel und das mache ich jetzt einfach
mal mit den kartoffeln und zwar sind das
glaube ich ein zentimeter große lücken
ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert das
kind auch jedes
und einfach die kartoffeln geschält habe
die maschine einfach fehlt der star
selbst keine komplette kartoffel
[Musik]
und so schnell hat wahrscheinlich noch
keiner gleichmäßig große würfel
geschnitten
ich zeige euch mal wie das hier drin
funktioniert vielleicht fragt ihr euch
das uns weiß da oben diese scheiben auch
sack versteckt jetzt auch noch kartoffel
drin nicht nach das gleich noch mal
durchlaufen und da schneidet die
kartoffel in 1 cm dicke scheiben und
hier unten ist es so über meinem
alligator schneidegerät oder beim
meister preis und einfach so ein gitter
aus messern und da fällt es dann eben
durch das mache jetzt mit gewürfelten
kartoffeln
die habe ich jetzt zb inwiefern hat da
kommt ein bisschen olivenöl mit rein
dann werden sie etwas gebraten ich kann
dann komplett draus machen mit eiern
oder ich gebe etwas zwiebel mit dazu
machte leckere kartoffel fahne mit wurst
oder mit zutaten die wurst oder ich
nehme meine äpfel kann damit meinen
apfelkuchen machen oder ein obstsalat
oder bauernsalat also ist das sind
eigentlich ganz viele sachen die man
damit machen kann und ich finde es echt
richtig cool und jetzt um seine macht
kämpft bei maschinen motiv fahrten macht
und zwar habe ich hier die nudelmaschine
den auftrag der wird auch da vorne drauf
gesteckt ich sage das jetzt nicht das
ist nämlich dass ähnliche prinzip und
das gleiche prinzip eigentlich
ich kann es nicht in folge einstecken
und kann jetzt im vierten ausbauen oder
auch meine form und meine wasser aus
wort und so einfach richtig cool
gestalten und ich habe jetzt drei
verschiedenen styles ist einmal die
private die mir die platten dann habe
ich hier noch nichts passiert die
aussage selber spaghetti machen und
einen tag der teller aufsatz mit dem
habe ich zum beispiel beim einer
unterwasserwelt die algen modelliert
oder man kann einfach getroffen einfach
diese bänder schleifen und so weiter und
da gibt es auch andere aufsätze und ich
würde es euch jetzt auch gar nicht vor
ich habe nämlich jetzt bald meine blase
an dem video und hab da zb auch meine
lasagne platten selber gemacht und hier
wieder nur die maschine ausgeholt und
ich finde sie zum zubehör teilt das ist
richtig cool weil wir zum beispiel ganz
gerne selbst gemachte nudeln essen
aber ich kann damit auch meine
maultaschen machen und es gibt auch
andere aufsätze wo ich zum beispiel
sogar pendeln nudeln selber macht man
also die die ihnen von hohl sind diese
spiele
und das finde ich auch richtig klasse
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal noch kurz
richtigen schneid für einsätze mittags
wenn wir uns von salat herstellen ich
habe da jetzt dem schreiben auch saft
bin und es geht wirklich total schnell
ich habe jetzt mein kopf salat schon
viel eingestellten jemand eisbergsalat
und jetzt mache ich hier an und hab dann
schon mein gemüse für meinen derart fein
geschnitten und kann das ist einfach so
benutzen was ich auch ganz gerne mag das
mache ich gern morgens dann bekommt man
das nehme ich ihnen so einen fehler in
der türkei schüssel eingepackt war ich
zeigt ihr euch ja da ich auch gesteckt
mit dabei das kommt übrigens da oben
drauf da kann ich dann dressing
einkommen kommt hier der salat rein das
pressen wenn er dann auch für arbeit ist
kann das ist ein bisschen nehmen über
den salat übergeben und
wir wissen dass ich habe euch jetzt mal
ein paar zusatz zubehörteile gezeigt ich
habe natürlich auch nicht alle
ich werde meinen im normalen fall
anschauen und zeigt euch jetzt aber mal
du warst bei mir ins bett jetzt im shop
alles frei ist
ich meine dass ich jetzt die can
durchschnitt unter kitchenaid derzeit
das sind die beiden einzigen maschinen
sich bei mir im shop anbietet weil ich
einfach von beiden von der qualität
überzeugt bin und sie beide wirklich
finde und karte kennt hirsch wirklich
qualitativen ich glaube für den
hausgebrauch nicht mehr zu überbieten
und ich sage ich jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz schnelldurchlauf alles was ihr
dabei ist also da ist natürlich die
maschine dabei hier mit diesen tricks
blitzschutz übrigens hat die maschinen
hitzeschutz kann ich gar nicht erwähnt
wenn die stadt dann koche und zum
beispiel super kocher und es wird eben
dann erhitzt die suppe und auf 60 grad
hat sie ganz kurz auf und örtlich weiter
und dann muss ich sagen je maschine ich
bin wieder da und dann muss ich da auf
diese taste gedrückt
auch dieses p und dann läuft sie wieder
weiter uns ist einfach ein hitzeschutz
falls sich zum beispiel mal aus ansätze
und kurz weg laufen und ich merke dass
die super hinten stand kocht und das
ganze
neben bei hoher drehzahl dann weiter
kein schild und rührt dann könnten muss
ich natürlich verbringen wenn man nicht
aufpasst und ich sagte ich bin dabei ich
weiß was jetzt einstellen dass der pc
schon finde ich eigentlich echt ganz gut
dann ist dabei einer schüssel noch eine
schlüssel und das ist auch etwas was ich
euch jemals erleben egal was wenn
küchenmaschine ihr habt ihr braucht
immer eine zweite schlüssel weil sobald
ihr die eine benutzt habt wandert die
meistens in die spülmaschine und dann
braucht ja auf jeden fall der zwei
beschlüsse dass ich immer ein muss ein
spritzschutz mit decke ich bin
spritzschutz becken ohne zu klappbaren
deckelnden nicht so gut weil ich eine
frau spielt damit dabei gegen mixa
wir haben hier ihre elemente an die
parteien sich nicht in meiner hand den
gummi auf platz dann haben wir die
fleischbranche dabei mit spritzgebäck
auch sonst und drei verschiedenen 1
setzen wir haben hier den dampfer ein
satz den ich super finde hier die
gewürzmühle mit dem vier gläser ich weiß
jetzt gar nicht wo mein viertes gleis
ist doch dass ich in der im
küchenschrank war da noch das gewürz
drin steckt dann haben wir den gemüse
schneider und das sind eben die sechs
messer mit dabei und das ist jetzt alles
etwas habe ich zusammen gestellt das
gibt es auch woanders so in der
kombination gar nicht das sind sachen
die ich super finde und dieses set
kostet jetzt statt 1750 euro bei uns im
shop 1199 euro
und ich hab euch ja schon gesagt dass
bei uns wird die kenwood die
finanzierungsmöglichkeit da ist das
heißt ihr könnt auch auf raten kaufen
aber ich persönlich bin der meinung man
sollte erst dann kaufen wenn man das
geld gespart haben ich halte ich so viel
von finanzierung das hatte ich euch auch
im letzten video schon gesagt und in
diesem set ist auch natürlich eine
gebrauchsanleitung mit dabei und auch
eine auf zdf deutschen video mit und da
erkennt man immer ganz genau was man
machen kann denn ich benutze meine
maschine zu meinem alltag jeden tag aber
in meinen videos benutze ich sind zwar
gelegentlich aber immer nur dann wenn
ich sage okay ich trete für ein teil
davon ich könnte aber auch mit den
händen kneten weil einfach nicht jeder
eine küchenmaschine hat und ich eben
rezepte für alle gestalten möchte jeden
der maschine haben wir auch keine hand
und fand ihr da nur fragen dazu haben
kann ich sie euch natürlich gerne
beantworten und wenn ich mal was nicht
weiß mag ich an meinem händler der eben
die maschine dann für mich versendet das
ist einfach hinter oder weiblich
erklären sich damit aus und sie haben
jederzeit an den wänden und ihr könnt
euch dann auch an ihn wenden oder an
mich das weiß in dem fall egal
falls dem internet gestellt da muss man
immer ein bisschen aufpassen ich bin da
gibt es firmen bieten dann reporter an
das heißt dieser maschine kommt dann zum
beispiel aus einem anderen land und dann
habe ich eine bedienungsanleitung dabei
nicht auf deutsch ist sondern zb auf
russisch oder slowenisch und dann könnt
ihr damit eigentlich im prinzip gar
nichts anfangen und oftmals entstanden
auch dieser mix mit einem rad oder band
oder edelstahlbereich und nicht aus
clans und das finde ich ziemlich schade
weil dieses mal denn schon das schönere
und bessere elf ja das war eigentlich so
grob alles über die kenwood was ich euch
mitteilen wollte alles ist noch nicht so
das größte und das gröbste und falls ihr
danach fragen habt dürft ihr euch
wirklich gerne bei uns melden m schavan
und sabine meine freundin die meinen
shop zu investieren betreuen oder diesen
job hauptsächlich betreue ich ein
bisschen die könnt euch auch fragen
beantworten
ihr könnt uns jederzeit schreiben auf
info erzählst orten welt.de und wie
gesagt weil ich mal nicht weiter weiß
packe ich einfach meinen händler
und wer hilft mir dann und euch weiter
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß bei der entscheidung ob wir
vielleicht
ihr wollt oder nicht und verwende ich
entscheidet ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat weil sie immer fragen
ab stellst dir bitte öffentlich unter
die kommentare weil dann haben auch
andere was davon und ich würde sagen ich
bereue meine küche auch dank eines
wieder weg bereitet nämlich das nächste
video vor
nächste woche werde ich übrigens das
feature video abtreten also noch mal
mein set vorstellen die eine sachen
richtig vorstellen
und da freue ich mich auch schon drauf
und dann den und schon ganz bald wieder
war ich noch ganz viele konzept videos
zwischendurch habe